wilmarie you're on the air hello I'm a
59 year old lady who has she had a
routine blood sheet and found to have
anemia had a colonoscopy and guess Oscar
P found that I had a tumor there had
that removed on the 9th of March so I
had a right Henry co-op to me removed
after surgery I had acts they found I
had a cloth on the lung because I was
having some breathing difficulties
they started me oil quick saying I then
had a hemorrhage at but and and I in
routine time okay stop a minute run
through a lot of stuff here unless you a
here marine that 90 kilos hygiene sorry
feels okay so that's 200 pounds and how
tall are you
that's four okay five foot four five six
four I'd like to see away 130s they need
to lose about 70 pounds here also did I
get it correct that you had did you have
your gallbladder removed is you have a
piece of your colon removed no pain to
my poem bed right he me come up to me
okay and let's see here you had a blood
clot in your lungs you're chronically
anemic did you have any skin problems
any eczema dermatitis or psoriasis none
okay what about respiratory stuff asthma
bronchitis I've had it been wrong kind
of over the years if I get a cold or flu
it so the queso cheese and you had your
any colostomy your Hemi allows to me
because why did you have liberal bowel
syndrome or colitis or alkalis what you
have well they found that a hidden emia
and then they sounded born because you
had anemia sorry you say they took out
your colon because you have anemia no I
hid anemia so they didn't did a
colonoscopy and a gastroscopy
and found that I had a tumor and my
colon a tumor
yes okay and so they removed the tumor
yes okay how long ago was that
not as much okay so this year yes okay
all right charmagne yeah they're okay
for Kiwi friend Murray from New Zealand
and she weighs 200 pounds she needs to
lose 70 pounds and also he's had was
this a malignant tumor was this a cancer
was this Nathan I'm not cancerous tumor
goal of me know was that that was a it
was a tumor
I came just tumor and Charmaine yeah see
she had portion record look like she had
a malignant tumor there she had a blood
clot in her lung she's 70 pounds
overweight chronically anemic what's
your basic underlying problem she's got
a good an intolerance and she's not able
to absorb yes that's why you guys
brought how does everyone so well also
yeah and so what would you give her to
support her immune system and give her
what she basically needs to lose that
weight - well you're on a gluten-free
diet no wheat barley railroads and none
of the bad stuff no oils no burnt animal
fat no none of that stuff no fried foods
so then I would get around to healthy
brain and heart packs to support all the
issues that she has okay and for the
weight loss I'd get around the Rev and
he can also add to the brain and heart
pack I would add the oceans gold and the
few coid C or the Z radical okay and
that's just order music system cancer
correct exactly yes i right process it's
guys sea cucumber net that's notorious
for dealing with cancer oh yes no choice
for supporting immune system when you
have a cancer issue and as so many
articles written in the New York Times
from the New York City School of
Medicine it's really a lot of great
research on sea cucumber and supporting
your music system when you have cancer
so that good choices
charmagne okay and then if you wouldn't
read give us a call every couple of
weeks let us know what your weight is
that
he put a dropper full underneath on 30
minutes for each meal we then absorb
their own tissues within 7 to 10 days
you should start losing a half a pound
or 2 pounds a day we look forward to
hearing from you